I suppose i get turned on my pressure high that's how i thrive yeah i spent three years getting my ass kicked in france and
then
literally eight years ten years like reading medicine
studying under some great chefs to really perfect my trade just show a little bit of passion to what a pure chef
Oh, i'll pay if you fly back to australia what's that believe nation it's evan my one word is believe and i believe in you
I believe in your potential and i want to see that thing that you've got inside you
explode out into the world to have a big impact for you your family and the world
So to help you on your journey today we're going to learn from
entrepreneur and celebrity chef gordon ramsay and my take on his top ten rules for success
volume 2 rule number one is my personal favorite and i'd love to know which one you guys like the best and as always guys
as you're watching if you hear something that really really resonates with you please leave it down the comments below and put quotes around it
So other people can be inspired and when you write it down it's much more likely, to stick for yourself as well
enjoy
how do you deal with stress gordon ramsay um good question and
Precious healthy it becomes stressful when you can't handle last and i don't think we should never sort of
misinterpreted the difference between passion and anger of course i get upset when things go wrong
if i was flipping burgers and dressing caesar salad then i'd be high-fiving everybody if i was a chef at tgi fridays and
doing barbecue wings with a sour dip that was sort of sat there for 30 days at a time
Then you'd see a completely different go around i decided not
To cook at that level i suppose i get turned on by pressure high that's how i thrive so
some of you you know
can can handle that enormous
amount
of pressure and i
Suppose more than anything i don't i don't think i've peaked yet that's the weird thing about it i don't i don't feel i've i've
Given everything i've got in food but after a cozumel ruin the meatballs what's the future and is now refused to cook
chef ramsay is frustrated not only by the chef but also by tatiana's lack of management for tenure
okay okay sister thank you business
honestly italian cafe wow what a joke
oh
don't leave
please don't leave
I don't know what to do i thought i just
it's just insane no restaurant anywhere in this country functions like that just help us because i can't i can't have it feel
when a chef out last tune owners already trust me there's something not quite right because if the owner
previously i eat charlie was that
Invested in his chef trust me he would have gone with him he would have gone with him it's not rocket science
tatiana are you a smart girl
Are you scared to upset somebody yeah you're happy to see all three family members onerous but they rely on you to manage the restaurant
They depend on you to give them that security i am not some chef that won't even take on board were you trying, to say
Spending therefore five minutes just watch what they do that's if he's you know happy to cook again
So i need a fire him i'm not asking to fire him i'm asking, to take responsibility i'm so embarrassed by
The restaurant in general and it's all my fault and i'm the only one to blame because, i'm the owner and
I'm doing such a horrible job
when all your orders are my first
put them in i want to close i guess i just have been walking around with like a sheet over my face and
Not seeing these little things that are so easy to see how mom and you talk to you now you go outside
i'm mad at myself i need to be the owner of this restaurant you
So fired i do have this
Ruthless way of approaching your character you're you who you are on kitchen nightmares hell's kitchen you have high standards?
professionally but it must be said on tv at least you do you attack chicken kitchen staff on their gender their appearance their intelligence
it seems like you're bigger than life in your reality your tv persona
is that for an american audience is that four four is that a character you're playing
first of all i don't attack anyone with gender that's for sure being put in that situation under intense pressure creates
you know pressure in terms of explosion
honestly if i was flipping burgers and dressing caesar salad then i'll be the happy chef in the world
Give me a slice of tuna for sashimi and no heat and trust me you'd see a different gordon ramsay
where you see a very cleverly edited
Scenario with 45-minute cut-down version i don't play in it at least suite that's nothing
To do with me all i do do is keep it real there's nothing poncey there's nothing made-up there's no autocue there's
No, come on let's get upset because it looks good it's drama
Unscripted and i can't tell you what's gonna happen because even i don't know what's gonna happen
But what i will tell you is when people tried to undermine me
Lie, to me lie to the customer cut corners and then try to
you, know sort of almost in an embarrassing way
Dictate to the customer that they know better in terms of trying to undermine their integrity
And that's where i'm going to cut their balls off
are you talking out your ear
Why don't you just sit down stop trying to cause trouble
Old stuff unfortunately it all starts changing the face shop?
So what you think is fresh it no longer fresh and those pork is out there are eating this
No, you can't i'm not gonna let you cook anymore yeah that's right you want to continue cooking
Do you think it's funny but
some food in the fridge i continue cooking fresh
To show your passion to water your chef
I'll pay if you fly to australia, so where do you imagine from oh yeah i mean passion garden still very early on in life
sadly and what do you do at the age of 19 you get bitter no i just wanted to get you even
So in that team spirited fashion kitchens function exactly the same way
But mum always told me to get off my ass and stop whinging about spilt milk go and look, for the next cow so
that's what my scottish background i think and if i can't work and continue to be that passionate about what i do
To be honest i'd rather not do it 20 years ago i got dealt a dysfunctional cars
my little brother became a heroin addict and my father became an alcoholic
what do i do i sit there and join my little brother or i'll become an alcoholic alongside my father
No, i got my ass i stopped for feeling sorry for myself
And i got on with it not on tv how competitive is and how fiercely competitive is the chef world
yeah, the tv part your question is very competitive
the majority chefs i know carla bath let alone 18 wrestlers across the world and they are
always striving to steal recipes or poacher number two or poacher maitre d or poach of customers will do something so
very competitive we have the michelin guide as our sort of standard bear out there that keeps us on our toes thirdly is
taking on competition everyone thinks that it's rife and it's difficult but competition is healthy
Every time a new russian opens up i'll make sure that if it's not
me one of my members of staff from the kitchen and the dining room of their
Over the competition there's so much to learn from a bad meal and so much
To gain from a good meal so staying in front of your
Competition is healthy so do you think you're tougher on hell's kitchen contestants in masterchef
To complete different competitions you know house kitchens by professionals and like i said even before i started
working on television like master my craft you know i spent three years get my ass kicked in france and then
literally eight years ten years like reading medicine studying under some great chefs to really perfect my trade
So then when i got a chance to sort of
Do my professional on television it was kitchen nightmares that really started first so that was real because i wanted these businesses to work
masterchef is completely different these are amateurs that have full-time jobs as
firefighters schoolteachers bank clerks and so
the journey
From apron to the finale they finished my professional chefs so the arc of that incredible
Monumental journey is so exciting
to see with professional chefs in health kitchens etc
i'm not going to tolerate their mistakes because they should know that stuff before they come anywhere near me
So many hours of tv that you're putting out is there ever a moment way of thought
Because you're not, sort of carefully thinking through sort of exactly how you're coming across on tv i'm diabetic i think there's always
Sort of regrets what i never do is sit there and ponder as if we've made a mistake
We all want to do is find a solution um i call as i said
Sometimes that's incorrect and by the end of day that's what you're going to get because i don't i don't sit there and pretend
so
Do i sit there and
Waste time no life's too short i was very fortunate to
be taught with some of the best chefs anywhere in the world and the most important lesson i learned for passing that knowledge on
And always asked that amazing question it just such a hands-on share freshmen turn who does the cooking up there well it's the same people
When i am there there's no
Difference so i have an unselfish way of teaching people to
Invest in their palate to get it as strong as mine i tried to save them as lazy to copy
anybody can copy so
take 25% of everything you've learned from other chefs and then put yourself on the plate and over the years of experience
reduce me less and improve yourself from that's
That's the foundation to becoming a great chef now watch very carefully first off to all the fellas have probably got
To scale it properly okay
right nice sharp knife
get comfortable to fish okay
nice forward and just let the knife do the work don't over pack the summer
otherwise you know bruises
just, memorize every little move he's making and i am just from freaking out i'm gonna slice through through the
bone halfway through i come down okay turn the salmon round
Hand on and just come all the way down?
let the knife
Do the work
down
first slice off
Gordon starts to work on the salmon like he's cutting through butter and suzi's next to me having a complete
orgasm watching
And i'm just thinking do not be fooled it is not that easy it's two months how
So there's my towel second portion offer the belly offer the top
portion size across the board nice and fat or out music
two four six eight ten twelve and fourteen
Thank you guys
So much
for watching i made this video because frank robert jean-pierre
Asked me to if there's something you'd like me to cover in a future top 10 check out the link in the description and go
and cast your vote i'd also love to know what did you learn from this video what lesson really hit home the hardest what are
You going to immediately apply somehow
To your life or to your business leave it down the comments below i'm really curious
To find out i also want to give a quick shout out
to ariza pereira thank you so much frieza for picking up a copy of my book your one word taking that picture
posting it online i really really appreciate your support and i'm so glad that you enjoyed the book thank you guys again for watching i
believe in you i hope you continue to believe in yourself and whatever your one word is much love i'll see you soon
here
Your ambitions you said you didn't you never set out to be famous you are clearly
incredibly ambitious you've got multiple tv projects here and in europe you publish cookbooks
you're opening more restaurants and pubs all over the world all the time
you're already wealthy and successful
do you want an international empire i'm exposing talent ready i
am the most unselfish chef anywhere in the world my team are no longer chefs they're partners and
Unfortunately i'm always the one that's sort of regarded is spreading himself too thin but there's 1500 of us now there's
1500 15 the team so if i wasn't propelling talent and
exposing talent and pushed him at the forefront you know in modern you know odd cuisine then they wouldn't be as talented as they are
So for me it's a way of not giving back to industry i hate that scenario but in terms of
Finding talent nursing it and then exposing so why don't you want you want to just
As big as it can grow oh there's no script everyone says how do you manage i don't
See it as tv i see it as work because it's incredibly fortunate position to be in but i i keep it real
so i i
i
i look at the success of something like the voice-over the last two or three years globally and the reason why that's become a
massive hit global is because the judge can actually turn it on and literally go on the stage and
belt out a single and inspire those individuals
Chefs exactly the same for me i don't have any problems looking vulnerable feeling under pressure or being?
in a position where we start from the bottom and we have to climb the ladder so i'm in it together so i see
that relationship with those contestants as
I'm in your boat you know i mean i'm in your camp i'm here for you use me to make you look good
So i don't tiptoe around it in a way that i want
To look down the barrel of an autocue and present as a presenter and i'm more on a hands-on
approach one of the big
Turning points in my career at the age of 33 is when i came back
France opened up my first restaurant good ramsay in chelsea and my ambition was to go on and win three michelin stars
an actor wants an oscar and a soccer player wants a world cup and i'm a chess point of view there's no higher than
three stars
So that night when we were inspected by every inspector across the world and the following day they asked for a meeting to be told
that the restaurant gordon ramsay in this year's guide will be featured with three michelin stars it just i don't know it made me stop
For five minutes and think you know what i've made it but i hadn't because winning it was one thing
maintaining it
it's ten times more difficult and for 15 years today still
we remain as london's longest three-star michelin but the biggest kick in the books for me was the next day going into my kitchen
serving this beautifully glazed sea bass the customer asking me for tomato fucking ketchup
it's true cars picked off
Are you kidding me i just want three mission stars i just cook the best sea bass in my entire career and you asked me
in tomato ketchup man get your white sneakers now at my restaurant
The most important work ever if you had to think of one word
That's most important, to you that sums you apple so it would be like a little beacon
table ignatian if you want to know what the most important one word is for tony robbins gary vaynerchuk
oprah winfrey will.i.am and howard schultz i have a very special secret video for you check the description for details